pit's please played okie dokie played
okie dokie you need to play dunky dunky
literature
you should play doki doki and later at
club I know it looks kind of weepy but
it gets really [ __ ] up after a while
wait don't cut open their club already
you late [ __ ] I knew about this game way
before your weed's fake Gaius something
Christian channel but you know what I'm
curious about this game so I will play
it thank you very much and not because
you are a complaint bad let's play Doki
Doki literature club this game is not
suitable for children or those who are
easily disturbed oh so it's gonna be
like one of those cute games that then
turn really evil individuals suffering
from anxiety or depression may not have
a safe experience playing this game for
cottony morons please visit great by
playing Doki Doki learish club you agree
that you are at least 13 years of age
then you can send to your exposure of
highly disturbing content maybe I'm
being a little too sceptic here right
off the bat with the amount of praise
this game as getting it must be good it
must be good the art looks great and
it's a free game too then he just said
did you say teams Santo st. oh oh I was
not ready for this oho I am lightly
bobbing my head to this you groove you
lose and I lost oh ok ok ok let's begin
a new let's play it's gonna be a daily
series it's been a while
sexy booty this someone please kill me
if anyone would like to come in and pop
one in the back while I played this that
would be great
hey I see an annoying girl running
towards me from the distance waving her
arms in the air like she's totally
oblivious to any attention she might
draw to herself
the girl is sorry my neighbor and good
friends since we were children you know
the kind of friend you'll never see
yourself making today but it just kind
of works out because you've known each
other for so long we used to walk to
school together on days like this but
starting around high school she would
oversleep more and more frequently and I
would get tired of waiting it but if
she's going to chase after me like this
I almost feel better off running away
wow what a dick move people used to do
that when I was a kid however I just
sigh and idle in front of the crosswalk
and let's say I already catch up to me
next time
I'm not keeping that boy said maybe but
only because I decided to stop and wait
for you you're saying that like you were
thinking about ignoring me that's me
beauty pay well if people stare at you
for acting weird and I don't want them
to think we're a couple or something
you're not that hot I'm sorry Sayuri
but you did wait for me after all I
guess you don't have it in you to be me
even if you want to I hate this
character already
whatever you say Sayuri hey we cross the
street together and make our way to
school as we draw near the street become
increasingly speckled with other student
making their daily commute by the way
PCP have you seen it in the clip to join
it a club I told you already I'm not
interested in joining any clubs I
haven't been looking either that's not
true
you told me you would join a club this
year
did I I'm sure it's possible that I did
in one of our many conversations where I
dismissive ly go along with whatever she
was going on about say or he likes to
worry a little too much about me when
I'm perfectly content just getting by on
average while spending my free time on
games an enemy what a life to live it I
was talking about how I'm worried about
worried that you won't learn how to
socialize or have any skills before we
call it
this [ __ ] is telling me how to
socialize excuse me your happiness is
really important to me
oh she's way over heads to us damn and I
know you're happy now but I die at the
thought of you becoming a need in a few
years because you're not used to being
one you trust me right don't make me
keep waiting you baby all right all
right I'll look at a few clubs if it
makes you happy no primer system will
you please promise me you training okay
I guess I'll try with you dad yay
why do I let myself get lectured by a
carefree girl more than that I'm
surprised I even let my several enter I
guess seeing her worry so much about me
makes me want to ease her mind at least
a little bit even if she does excite dad
you rate everything inside her head
we're in school hi everybody
the school day is this ordinary as ever
and it's over before I know it but
that's not how school works okay it's
never over before you know it after I
pack up my things I start blankly at the
wall looking for an ounce of motivation
clubs say Ari wants me to check out some
clubs I guess I have no choice but to
start with the enemy Club sorry sorry
must have come into the classroom while
I was spacing out I look around and
realize that I'm the only one left in
the classroom if Ana kid she came in out
of the class name but I figured you City
history a through K me
and if me you even wait a minute ease
any breathe you don't need to wait up
for me
our voice is sucked up okay it's going
to make you late to your own club we say
you may need to me gives me three taking
game you know what we have you can
Kingdom eager you say hurry there's no
way I'm going to your club savories vice
president of the literature Club that
sounds really boring not that I was ever
aware that she had any interest in
literature in fact I'm 99% sure she only
did it because she thought it would be
fun to help start a new club since she
was the first one to show interest after
the one who proposed a club she
inherited the title vice president that
said my interest in literature is
guaranteed to be even less yeah I'm
going to the anime club why do you care
so much anyway
I can't do it
clip yesterday I would bring in a baby
and that's tsukimi cupcake is it
everything well she made yeah you have
to go now hey don't make promises you
can't keep
I can't tell if C or E is really that
much of an airhead or if she's so
cunning I start playing all this app I
let alone say hey Fang I stopped by for
a cupcake okay let's go and that's today
marks a day I sell my soul for a cupcake
what i DJ glee follow saber across the
school in upstairs a section of the
school I rarely visit being generally
used for third-year classes and
activities say already full of energy
swings open the classroom door
everyone then a member is here I told
you don't call me a new member
hey I glanced around the room
welcome to the literary click Church
Julia Clare Clare this is why I don't do
reading games Jesus Christ it's a
pleasure meeting you
Sayuri so who is next says old sailor II
always says nice things about you oh my
god what voice series seriously
you brought a boy wait I'll get it
eventually way to kill the atmosphere a
pizza bear what a nice surprise
welcome to the clip all words escape me
in this situation this club it's full of
incredibly cute girls Wow which one is
your wife the younger sister the older
sister or perhaps dead girl next door
type leave a comment now
[Music]
sorry netsuke the girl with the sour
attitude whose name is apparently
netsuke is one I don't recognize her
small figure makes me think she's
probably a first-year she is also the
one who made cupcakes according to
saiary already says that quietly into my
ear then turns back towards the other
girls
and if it's you read it's maddening you
don't say things like that
Yuri you appears complete compared ibly
more mature and timid seems to have a
hard time keeping up with people like so
Yuri Natsuki oh well it's nice to meet
both of you
it seems like you already know money can
say three that's right
it's great to see you again pizza pay oh
wow
it's out Monica smiles sweetly we don't
know each other well we rarely talk but
we were in the same class last year
Monica is that really a Japanese name I
never heard it Monica was probably the
most public or in class smart beautiful
athletic nice rack basically completely
out of my league so having her smile at
me so genuinely feels a little cakes
hey I made them out get up then how
about I make some tea as well the girls
have a few desk arranged to form a table
as Sayuri mentioned it's been widened so
that there is one space next to Monica
and one space next to Sayuri
NAT so Ian and Yuri walk over to the
corner of the room we're not see you
grabs a rap tray and you're reopens to
closet still feel like awkward I take a
seat next to Sayuri
maybe this club isn't so bad after all
netsuke proudly marches back to the
table train hane okay are you ready
that's if you lift the foil of the the
trade to real adult doesn't white fluffy
cupcakes decorated to look like little
cats oh my god that is so cute the
whiskers are drawn with icing and little
pieces of chocolate were used to make
ears oh my god that is so Ken
I had no idea you were so good at baking
netsuke he will you know
just hurry just hurry up and take what I
mean oh it's fine Sayuri grabs one first
then Monica I follow Sayuri walk talks
with her mouth full and has already
managed to get icing on her face
I turned the cupcake around in my
fingers looking for the best angle to
take a pay netsuke is quiet I can't help
but notice her sneaking glances in my
direction if she is she waiting for me
to take a bite I finally bye damn the
icing is sweet and full of flavor
I wondered if she made it herself this
is really good
Thank You netsuke why do you think he me
it's not like hey haven't I heard this
somewhere before
made them for you or anything oh hey I I
thought technically you did say or he
said well maybe but not for you you you
dummy alright alright I give up on that
Sookie's weird logic and dismissed the
conversation URI returns to the table
carrying a tea set she carefully places
a teacup in front of each of us before
setting down the tea pot next to the
cupcake tray where's the literature in
this club okay so far it's just girls
and sweets
you keep a whole tea set in the
classroom don't worry the teachers give
us permission after all doesn't it hot
cup of tea help you enjoy a good book
fair enough I guess uh I guess what
Jesus hey hey hey don't let yourself get
intimidated you're just trying to
impress e and that's not it insulted URI
looks away I mean that you know I
believe you
well tea and reading might not be a past
time for me but at least but at least I
enjoy tea I'm glad you're a faintly
smiles herself in relief what the hell
is happening here Monica raises an
eyebrow then smash at me so what made
you consider literature clip I was
afraid of this question something tells
me I shouldn't tell Monica that I was
practically dragged here by syuri well I
haven't joined any club's yet and she
always seemed really happy here so
that's a great reason as any oh sorry
that's okay
don't be embarrassed
we'll make sure you feel right at home
okay as president of literature club
it's my duty to make the club fun and
exciting for MPP Monica I'm surprised
how come you decided to start your own
Club you could probably be a board
member for any of the major clubs
where's your leader of the Bay Club last
year Hey so you know to be honest I
can't stand no the politics around the
major Cape if it's like nothing but
arguing about the budget and publicity
and how to prepare for events I much
rather take something I personally enjoy
and make something special atomy and if
it encourage others to get into
literature then I'm fulfilling that tree
really great leader
Yuri nods in agreement then I'm
surprised there aren't more people in
the club yet it must be hard to start a
new club you could put it you could
paint it that way not many people are
very interested in putting out all the
effort to start something brand new
especially when it's something that
doesn't grab your attention like
literature you have to work hard to
convince people that you're both fun and
worthwhile but it makes cool events like
the festival much more important I'm
confident that we can really grow this
club before we graduate read every when
we'll do our best
everyone enthusiastically agrees what a
great time such different girls all
interested in the same goal my dear
Monika must have worked really hard just
to find these three maybe that's why
they were all so delighted by the idea
of a new member joining though I still
don't really know if I can keep up with
their level of enthusiasm about
literature so pizza pay what kind of
things do you like to read well
considering how lil I bred these past
few years I don't really have a good way
of answering that manga I mutter quietly
to myself half joking netsuke ahead Matt
Sookie's head suddenly / except it
looked like she wants to say something
but she keeps quiet not much of a reader
egg yes well that can change what am I
saying
I spoke without thinking after seeing
your sad smile anyway what about you
jury Yuri well let's see
Yuri traces the remembers she kept with
her finger my favourites are usually
novice that build deep and complex
fantasy worlds the level of creativity
and craftsmanship behind them is amazing
to me and telling a good story in such a
foreign world is equally impressive Yuri
goes on clearly passionate about her
reading she seems so reserved and timid
since the moment I walked in but it's
obvious by the way her eyes lit up that
she finds her comfort in the world of
books not people but you know I like a
lot of things stories with deep
psychological m elements usually emerged
me as well isn't it amazing how a
radicand so deliberately take advantage
of your lack of imagination to
completely throw you off for a loop
foreshadowing everybody anyway I've been
reading a lot harder lately
foreshadowing again ah I've read a hard
book once I desperately grass something
I can relate to at a minimum level at
this rate you might as well be having a
conversation with the rock
really I wouldn't have expected that
Yuri
for someone as gentle as you I guess you
could say that but if a story makes you
think or takes me to another world then
I really can't put it down so real
horror is often very successful at shake
changing the way you look at the world
if only for a brief moment oh why is
that weird I just
that's against I start over to me for a
split second this is so strange
what is happening what am i doing never
mean that's right usually like to create
a pet usually right - right usually like
to write about cute things don't you
netsuke you left a piece of scrap paper
behind last Club meeting it looked like
you were working a poem called give it
back
fine fine your kid cakes new pins
everything you do is
juices get you I say he already shitless
up behind that's again puts a hand on
her shoulder I'm not cute
that's the key you write your own poems
I get some teams where do you keep I
think that's impressive
why did you share them sometime no
that's a gear bertrise
he waited leaked in ah not a very
confident writer yet I understand how
Natsuki feels sharing that level of
writing takes more than just confidence
the truest form of writing is writing
there one writing to oneself you must be
willing to open up to your readers
exposing your vulnerabilities and
showing even the deepest reaches of your
heart do you have a writing experience
to URI maybe if you share some of your
work you can set an example and help
Natsuki feel more comfortable enough to
share her I guess it's the same for URI
[Music]
we all sit in silence for a moment
okay I have an idea everyone nuts again
your liquid quiz galley ad Monica let's
all go home and write a poem of our own
then next time we meet we'll all share
them with each other that way everyone
is even plus now that we have a new
member I think it will help us all get a
little more comfortable with each other
and strengthen the bond of the club
isn't that rad pizza pay money get
smiles warmly at you once again hold on
there's still one problem yeah but it's
dad now that we're back to the original
topics of me joining the club I bluntly
came forward with what's been on my mind
the entire time
I never said I would join this club
Saori may have convinced me to stop by
but I never made any decision I still
have other clubs to look at and I lose
my train of thought
all four girls stare back at me with
dejected eyes how can you say no to four
I am a wife who's just one maybe to hell
no three I'd rather burn in hell for you
just can't
but I'm sorry I thought you were oh I
different I'm defenseless again these
girls how am I supposed to make a
clear-headed decision when it's like
this that's if that is if writing poems
a surprise I need to pay in order to
spend every day with these beautiful
girls right okay I decided I'll join the
literature Club everybody gay one by one
the girl's eyes lit up Sayuri wraps her
arms round me jumping up and down oh hey
you really did scare me for a moment if
you really just came in for cupcakes I
would be super pissed then that makes it
official
welcome to the literature Club yay ah
thanks I guess okay everyone I think
with that we can officially end today's
meeting on a good note everyone remember
tonight's assignment write a poem to
bring the next meeting so we can all
share mónica looks over at me once more
pizza pie I look forward to seeing how
you express yourself yeah
okay can I really impress the class star
Monica with my MODY mediocre writing
skills I already feel anxiety welling up
inside me meanwhile the girls continued
to teach at at URI and netsuke clean up
their food
[Music]
that's right saya and I never walk home
together anymore because she always
stayed after school for Cleanse sure
might as well with that the two of us
depart the club room and make our way
home the whole way my mind wanders back
and forth between the four girls Sayuri
netsuke Yuri and of course Monica well I
really will I be will I really be happy
spending every day after school in a
literature Club perhaps I'll have the
chance to grow closer to one of these
girls all right I'll just need to make
the most of my circumstances and I'll
make sure a good fortune will find me
and I guess that starts with writing a
poem tonight wait I actually have to
write a poem what pick words you think
your favorite club member will like
something good might happen with whoever
likes are pulling the most what okay so
I'm gonna go with but there was nuts
Akita Yuri and Yuri
I think Yuri is my Bey step but so
extraordinary death Marshman so she like
horrors right that's what I picked up on
so let's go with death
[Music]
and she liked fantasy horror no actually
like that one okay adventure maybe all
she liked that mention love
oh my god I'm picking all the wrong
[Music]
agonizing okay she really likes all the
bad stuff sadness
what kiddies definitely pure [ __ ] this
is hard man anger of course that's her
[Music]
uncanny yes frightening yes easy
Reid was our nice gravy our dessert as
well melancholies her fantasies what
[Music]
captive Inferno fear what
oh I don't know who we impressed here
actually hey again Pizza Bay glad to see
you didn't run away from us hahaha I
took a quick break glad to see you
didn't run away on us hey man don't
worry this might be a little strange for
me but at least keep my word I at least
keep my word well I'm back at literature
Club I was the last to come in so
everyone else is already hanging out
thanks for keeping your promise pizza
pay I hope this isn't too overwhelming
of a commitment for you making you dive
headfirst into literature when you're
not accustomed to it
come on Rocky deserves any slack
sigh you already told me you didn't even
want to join any clips if you and last
year too
I don't know if you plan to just come
here and hang out or what hoping to get
some ass boy
hell yeah I'll join any literature club
buddy but if you don't take us seriously
then you won't see the end of it netsuke
you You certainly have a big mouth for
everyone who keeps her manga collection
in the club room oh Singha but dinga
that's a good find yourself stuck
between saying Monica and manga we
swiftly defeated Natsuki perhaps plugs
back in her into her seat
if you mean baby we're giving me a pee
make it clean Mimi how dependable say
alright that's because your room is so
messy it's distracting and you almost
set your house on fire once you two are
really good friends thank you I might be
a little jealous hey you need pizza kid
became become Sayuri
as usual Sayuri seems oblivious to the
weird situation you just put me into oh
yeah even sympathy you know
wait Sayuri me not really Debbie Shh
it's really nothing
what what is it yeah never made say we
made it sound like a big deal when it's
really nice what do I do
II I'm sorry Yuri I wasn't thinking I
guess that means it's up to me to rescue
this situation hey don't worry about it
first of all I wasn't expecting anything
in the first place
so any nice gesture from you is a
pleasant surprise it'll make me happy no
matter what is is that so yeah I won't
make it a big deal if you don't want it
to be alright well here
Yuri reaches into her bag and pulls out
a book I didn't want you to feel left
out
so I picked out a book that I thought
you might enjoy Oh best girl you're a
it's a short read so it should keep your
attention even if you don't usually read
Oh best girl
and we could you know read it together
discuss it if you wanted this this is
how it's this girl accidentally being so
cute she even picked out a book she
thinks I like despite me not me natural
reading like you're a thank you I'll
definitely read this try
enthusiastically take the book Hey well
you can read it at your own pace I look
forward to hearing what you think now
that everyone settled in I expect Monica
to kick up some schedule activities for
the club but that doesn't seem to be the
case
Sayuri and Monika are heading having a
cheery conversation in the corner
you're his face is already buried in a
book I can't help but notice her intense
expression like his weight when she was
waiting for this chance
maybe not Sookie is rum rummaging around
in the closet man it looks like no one
wants to be bothered today i slumped
down into the nearest desk how am I
supposed to occupy myself with something
literature related by myself like this I
guess I could always read some of the
book URI gave me obviously that's the
right thing to do right now but I'm
feeling a little too tired to believe I
could probably fall asleep right now I
close my eyes and end up listening and
on your thyroids conversation with
Monika could be Julie the clip see hmm
well we can't give up
the festival is our chance to show
everyone what there it sure is all about
the problem is that the idea of
literature Club serves to dense and
intellectual to be fair you have must
have extremely high IQ but it's not like
that at all you know we just need a way
of showing that to everyone something
that speaks to their creative minds
they didn't send a bindi
what do you mean even if we commit with
the most friending ami-nee busy Willie
came in first please
lyrics Jeremy they was very important to
figure it out you get people to show up
in the first place
no limping this and after they came we
can do it the thing to speak to that
greeted me what is this
Saira is taking this really seriously
it's rare to hear her deliberately
likely talking deliberate hmm that's a
good point in that case do you think
food will do the trick
you ain't King well I guess we could
good thinking
you invited all my friends good thinking
oh hi my nuts
hi Monica that's the kid would love to
do that that's a comida base camp geeks
that works perfectly
that wasn't why you suggested it haha
get cake baking cupcakes it is then
anyway we still need to work out the
details of the event itself I find
myself smiling in the end Sayuri is
still her usual self by therein lies the
unexpected reason I admire her no no you
don't like her unlike me was trouble
finding any motivation at all Sayuri can
put her mind to things and make them
come to life I suppose that's why I
ended up letting her get on my case
about things I can't help but wonder
what it would be like to see the world
through her eyes that's too close I
opened my eyes to find se or his face
filling my vision I nearly fought out of
my chair
wait it's Mia material
it's your foot sleeping like that that's
our school really have a napping Club
you sting a blinking itchy
never you in a collab you can have this
tape for any meanie you know it needs to
be don't say that so loud I glanced over
my shoulder to see if Monica overheard
it's true
yeah I know I know you're always looking
out for me so Yuri that's the problem
what about you you look out for me
better than you look out for yourself
you're still over sleeping every day
aren't you that's not very convincing
how many days is past week have you
gotten up on time I know it meda pretty
pretty Tootsie I can't even do that
look say you're a it's written all over
you II say a glances around herself baby
you were clearly in a rush this money
look your hair is sticking out all
around here I run my fingertips down the
side of sailors say you were here trying
to straighten out oh oh that's a good
move that's a good move man you really
need to brush this for this my really
educate me I won't fall for that there's
more than just your hair look your bow
isn't straight either
and there's two-faced stain in your
collar right there I try to wipe off the
state all that's in it that's in the
titov region of course they win
nobody's gonna tell you about it because
they don't want you to embarrass you
fortunately I don't care about that and
you don't even keep your blazer button
up
seriously saiary why do you think you
don't have a boyfriend yet me sorry but
you'll thank me later I'll start to
putting our blazer from the button once
you see how much better looks you'll
change your mind
[Music]
what is a Miss just thinking here we
released River friend you did see Kensie
hey don't say that
you'll make me feel weird and stupid
about it Vicky do in hippie realities ah
I guess he be careful the bread you
might cut ha why is this one so hard of
course I struggle to fully close the
button err a chick
does this thing even fit you properly
did we make Betty Oh
if you ever button it you would have
noticed sooner that it doesn't fit you
anymore what are you smiling about
don't say that out loud anyway you look
much better now so uh why does it feel
strange to see Sayuri's blazer burn up
like that but it's so tough this is
really strange for me to read I hope
you'd realize that
[Music]
sorry hey something I brought us our
blazing ones more syrup it's arms are
out and twirls around so if I keep
eating Peyton Danny won't get away from
me
what kind of logic is that and why are
you saying that that's like a good thing
because if I hit it boyish pretty then
he wouldn't make me UDC cookies and you
take medicating me than anyone else
right anyway
[Music]
so that's why I keep I'm keeping it
unbuttoned
stop saying all these impaired things
things if I didn't say anything
embarrassing II jeez well anyway just
focus on trying to wake up a little
earlier Oh only if you focus on getting
to be really fine fine it's a deal
I guess we really are better taking care
of each other then we are taking care of
our teeth yeah I guess so huh so maybe
you should come wake me up this morning
[Music]
you're doing it again sorry
happy I was joking with you but it's
impossible to tell with you sometimes
okay everyone thank god someone else
hey Monica suddenly calls out why don't
we share our poems the pose we wrote now
this beauty I can't wait to read this
yeah the same I fail to sound
enthusiastic but series still trots a
way to retrieve her poem by the way do
you did you remember to write a poem
last night yeah my relaxation ends I
can't believe I agreed to do something
so embarrassing
I couldn't really find much inspirations
as I never really done this before well
now that everyone's ready why don't you
find someone to share with I can't wait
Sayuri Monica enthusiatic pull out their
poems I'm really curious about this poem
thing say your is on wrinkle sheet of
loose-leaf torn from a spiral notebook
on the other hand Monica wrote her sin
come in a composition notebook I can
already see Monica a pristine
handwriting from where I sit that's
again you reluctantly complies while
reaching into their bags I do the same
myself
um I kinda want Sayuri's poem first I'm
definitely most compared comfortable
sharing it with Sayuri first she's my
good friend after all
oh it's who I share it with no idea
which it to get ready Sayuri you must be
seriously overreacting I'm not a good
writer at all
I honestly have no idea what I'm doing
wait maybe they swim either
haha I'm sure your as opinion has to be
a little bit more constructive than this
maybe even otsuki's are you sure you
don't like it just because I wrote it
yeah I'm sure that's part of me I think
I understand you better than a lot of
people you know so when I read you it's
not just it's like I can feel your
spirit Sara hugs the sheet against her
chest you're so weird Sayuri she clearly
wants to [ __ ] you really pretty believe
me not to mention the fact that I'm
standing in front of you in the club
room well of course I'm not really into
yet but that doesn't mean I'll break my
promise see before HP did then you
didn't you know Tran new things for
other people but everything only really
good for T thanks a URI I'm not sure if
they already sees the full picture of my
mode of him then again I can't deny that
she's part of the reason I joined
knowing how much this means to her at
all
I'm gonna make sure you have miss your
finger okay there would be my way of
thank you all right I'm going to hold
you to do that then now you remarked on
Jamie
don't worry I really mean it we'll see
about that
[Music]
it makes me feel like you missed me
kissing my forehead you helped me out of
bed making me rock Judah sleepy from my
eyes are you asking me to commit him
play are you testing me to wish my way
araignee tea I look up at the sky blue
it's a secret but I'd be trusted to if
it wasn't for you I would sleep forever
oh sorry this is just a guess but did
you wait until this morning to write
this little B you can't answer just a
little bit to a yes-or-no question well
at least that makes me feel a little
better at myself do you be me I don't
think it was that bad oh and because she
said I won't break this ice - cream I
beat oh yeah I didn't mean to say that
it was a bad poem it came out nice or
how should I put it it sounds just like
you yeah especially the last line even
though you were late to school it's bad
pinky well I guess there's no point in
arguing anyway thanks for showing me
Monika's beep oh yeah
but next time I won't forget and I'm
gonna read the big poof ever well I
guess I'll I look forward to all right
so let's go Yuri next hmm
Yuri stares at the poem a minute pass is
more than enough time for her to finish
reading oh sorry I forgot to start
speaking um it's fine don't force
yourself I'm not I just need to put my
thoughts into words hold on okay this is
your first time writing a poem right
yeah why do you ask I'm just making sure
I guess that he might be after reading
through it oh so it's that bad huh no
did I just raise my voice oh I'm sorry
Yuri bears her face in her hands I
couldn't help but notice that it it's
been several minutes and we really
haven't gotten no anyway um I might take
Yuri and oh it might take your a while
to get used to new people it's fine I
didn't really notice what you were
saying okay um it's just that there are
specific writing habits that are usually
typical of new writers and having been
through that myself I kind of learned to
pick up on them I think the most notable
thing I recognize in new writers is that
they try to make their style very
deliberate in other words they tend to
pick a writing style separate from the
topic matter and they form fit the two
together the inner soul is that both the
style and the expressiveness are
weakened
once you refines her train of thought
it's as if her demeanor totally changes
her stammering is completely gone as she
sounds like an expert of course that's
not something you can be blamed for
there are so many different skills and
techniques that go into writing even a
singing poet not just finding them and
building them but getting them to work
together is probably the most
challenging part it might take you some
time but
all comes we practice and learning by
example and trying new things I also
hope that everyone else in the club
makes you Valley make gives you valuable
feedback netsuke can be a be a little
biased though by us how well nevermind I
shouldn't be talking about people like
that sorry it's okay I'm not sure if
your is apologizing to herself to me or
not Sookie do you mind if I read your
poem now please do I'd love to share my
thought process behind it
here is smiles dreaming Li as if that's
a rare opportunity for her which itself
is kind of funny after all isn't this
supposed to be a literature Club ghost
under light the tendo's of my hair
illuminates beneath the amber glow
bathing it must be this one the last
remaining street lights to have
withstood the test of time the last yet
to be replaced by the sickening blue
green hue of the future I bathe calm
breathing air of the present by living
in the past the light flickers I flick
her back that was beautiful
I'm I'm sorry I have such terrible
handwriting what I wasn't thinking that
at all but it took you so long to read
ah well I just don't read scripts very
often
I actually think your handwriting is
pretty hey that's a relief also I like
the poet even though it's short it was
really descriptive it wasn't too short I
usually write longer puns not at all
I'm really glad you like it I'll be
honest since it's our first time sharing
I wanted to write something a little
more mild something easy to judge digest
I suppose are you into ghosts Yuri Oh
Yuri means ghost in Japanese he
actually the story or is it you may know
I don't know now I'm confused
actually the story isn't about ghosts at
arpita's pay really I must have totally
missed the point well I suppose you did
up only glanced over it after all but
remember that poems often express their
own thoughts feelings and experience in
their work they usually do more than
tell a simple story or paint a picture
in this case perhaps the subject of the
poem is only being symbolically compared
to a Gus lingering in our last remaining
place of comfort unable to let go over
the past and soon to be left with
nothing that's a lot more solemn putting
it that way
I'd even thought of that that's
impressive
it's nothing really well it makes me
happy that you think that just remember
that it won't be long before you pick up
on these things - yeah maybe you're
right I guess I'll have to keep trying
I'm counting on you all right we got two
more we'll end with Monica I think Oh
God well it's about what I experienced
from someone like you that's a little
pun when excuse me it's not like it's
like I said it was bad
I just stand there walking emotions so
basically it's not cute enough for your
taste do you want to get smacked I'll
pass
they'll anyway I need to show you man I
like you like Eagles can fly monkeys can
climb crickets can leap horses can race
I'll skim sweet tea to skim bronde
Eagles can fly people can try but that's
about it
[Music]
what in the world
yeah I told you you weren't gonna like
it I like it
what just be on it I am wait why you so
convinced that I wouldn't like it
because everyone high school things that
running has to be all sophisticated
stuff so people don't even take my
writing seriously but isn't the point of
poems - for people to express himself
your writing style of wouldn't it make
your message any less valid yes exactly
I like when it's easy to read but it's
it's but it hits your hair like in this
piece so you never won around they do
great things give me really
disheartening so I decided to write a
bit yeah I understand but the other nice
thing about simple writing is that it
puts more weight on the work I like it's
set up for a rhyme at the end but then
made it all flat on purpose it helps
bring out the feeling in the last layer
so you did I guess more went into it
than I realized
I liked her poem
why am i reading poems in a videogame
and I'm genuinely entertained by it haha
that's what it means to me about I'm
glad you learned something didn't expect
that from you
the youngest one of you did you I guess
not you didn't expect that burning I
decide to humor her with the last
comment I don't really care how old
everyone is but if netsuke is feeling
proud then I won't take that away from
her
alright where Monica left hype it's bang
having a good time so far oh yeah good
glad to hear it
by the way since you're new and
everything if you ever have any
suggestion for the club like new
activities or things we can do better
I'm always listening don't be afraid to
bring things up okay alright I'll keep
that in mind of course I'll be afraid to
bring things up I'm much better off just
going with the flow and not until I'm
more settled in anyway want to share
your pond with me it's kind of
embarrassing but I guess I have to hey
don't worry pizza pan we're all a little
embarrassed you know but it's sort of
buried that we all learn to get past
soon yeah that's true
I had Mona get my poem hmm I like this
one it makes me think of something
Sayuri would like is that so you and C
are really good friends right I wouldn't
be surprised if you had those sort of
things incoming oh well hey we may be
good friends but saya and I are actually
really different hmm well that may be
the case but maybe there are also
similarities that you wouldn't expect
the way she talks about you it sounds
like you two are really care about each
other well B even if you show it in
different ways it ends up being more
similar than you think so I think that's
the kind of vibe I get when reading your
poem
you sure you're not reading into this
too much ha ha ha
it could be oh gosh I sound like Yuri
but in any case Sara's writing has a has
kind of a gentle feel to it I can tell
she likes exploring with emotions like
happiness and sadness who knew that
someone so happy would enjoy it sad
things too
I wish we had clubs in our schools it
seems so great maybe it's just glorified
for obviously well we'll see where he
goes yeah that's totally unexpected well
each to our own you shouldn't be afraid
to experiment a little bit either
I'm sure I'll end up trying different
things in life it could take a while
before I feel comfortable doing this
that's ok I love to see you try new
things that's the best way to find the
kind of style that suits you everyone
else might be a little bit biased
towards their own kind of styles but I
always help you find what suits you the
most so don't force yourself to write
the way everyone else wants you to write
it's not like you have to worry about
impressing them or anything
ha ha ha ha ha anyway do you want to
read my poem now don't worry it's not
very good you sound pretty confident for
someone who claims to not be very good
well that's because I have to sound
confident that doesn't mean I always
feel that way you know I sink
well let's me
hole in the wall it couldn't have been
me see the direction the spackle
protrudes a noisy neighbor an angry
boyfriend I never know I wasn't home I
peer inside it for a clue no I can't see
I real blind like a film left out of the
Sun but it's too late my retinas already
scorched with a permanent copy of the
meaningless image it's just a little
hole it wasn't too bright it was too
deep stretching forever into everything
a hole of infinite choices I realized
now that I wasn't looking in I was
looking now and he on the other side
just looking in I was a glory hole I
like that I was cute so what do you
think hmm it's very freedom if that's
what you call it sorry I'm not really
the right person to ask for feedback
that's okay yeah that kind of style has
gotten pretty popular nowadays that is a
lot of poems I've been putting emphasis
on timing between words and lines when
performed out loud it can be really
powerful what was the inspiration behind
this one
well I'm not sure I know how to put it I
guess you could say that I had some kind
of epiphany recently it's been
influencing my palms to be an epiphany
yeah something like that
I'm kind of nervous to talk about deep
stuff like that because it's kind of
coming on strongly maybe after everyone
is better friends with each other anyway
here's Monica's writing tip of the day
some sometimes when you're writing a
poem or a story your brain gets to fix
it could fixated on a specific point if
you tried so hard to make it perfect
then you'll never make any progress just
force yourself to get something down on
the paper and tied it up later another
way to think about it is this if you
keep your pen in the same spot for too
long they'll get a big dark puddle of
ink so just move your hand and go with
the flow that's my advice for today
thanks for listening whoo I guess that's
everyone I glanced around the room that
was a little more stressful than I
anticipated
it's as if everyone is judging me for my
mediocre writing abilities even if
they're just being nice there's no way
my opponents can stand up to theirs this
is a literature club after all I say hey
I guess that's what I ended up getting
myself into across the room so you're in
Monica are happily chatting my aunt's
land on Uranus Sookie they gingerly
exchanged sheets of paper Shang there
respective puns as they read in tandem I
watch each of their expression change
that's Aquis I prefer Oh in frustration
meanwhile Yuri smiled sadly did you say
something
oh it's nothing because they're the
complete opposites not to get
dismissively returns upon to the desk
with one hand I guess you could say it's
PC ah thanks your sis here yeah did you
complete did he completely miss the
symbolism or something it's clearly
about feeling mean for giving up how can
I pick you I know that I just meant the
language I guess I was trying to say
something nice hey you mean you have to
try that hard to come up with something
nice to say thanks but that really
didn't come and ate it home well I do
have a couple of suggestions if I was
looking for suggestion I would have
asked someone who actually liked it
which people date by the way that you
relate inputs if I dictum sebacean dead
I gladly give you some detention of my
own pitiful excuse me I appreciate the
effort but I spent a long time inside
auditioning my writing staff I don't
expect it to change anytime soon unless
of course I come across something
particularly inspiring which I haven't
yet in pizza-pie like my poem to you now
he even told me he was impressed by it
that's a oh that's a good Sunday staying
set oh I didn't realize you were so
impressed invested in trying to impress
any member Yuri
hey that's not what I uh you're just
your race ends up as well maybe you're
just jealous that pizza pie appreciated
my advice more than he appreciates yours
how do you know we didn't appreciate my
advice move are you that full of your
shoe
catfight no if I was full of myself I
would delivery to go out of my way to
mix everything I do
overly cutesy oh well you know what I
wasn't the one whose boobs magically
grew a size bigger as soon as pity buy
started showing up netsuke that's the
key that's a little
this doesn't evolve you make very
suddenly both girls turned towards me as
if they just noticed I was standing
there
poochy back she's just trying to make me
look bad if she could get overhead never
learn to proceed but simple writing is
more effective then this wouldn't have
happened in the present what's the point
of making your poem all concluded for no
reason that the meaning should jump out
of that read it not forth enjoy a picnic
maybe explain it to repeats me wait
there's a reason we have so many deep
and expressive words in our language
it's the only way to convey complex
feeling and meaning the most effectively
avoiding them is not only unnecessary
limiting yourself it's also a waste you
understand that right pizza pie ah well
how did I get ready to this in the first
place it's not like I know anything
about writing but whoever I agree with
they'll probably think more highly of me
[Music]
that's a key net secure glares at me
drying up any words I had in my mouth so
instead I turn to yuri yuri expressions
so defenseless that I can't bring myself
to say anything to her
sorry yeah everyone is fighting is
making Sayuri uncomfortable
how can you two keep fighting when you
know you're making your friend feel like
this
well that's her that's her problem this
isn't about her hey I agree it's unfair
for others to interject their own
feelings into our conflict yeah Lucy
Yuri wants to tell you what a stuck-up
jerk sheathe be Shh she would never
it's your immaturity that made her upset
in the first place excuse me are you
live exactly wait everybody who exactly
where nobody likes hey Vicky Gary I gave
it my friend
I said you might never went to get along
and be happy my friends and wonderful
people it'd be Jamie but if I give him
any feelings it's okay we made it being
a beautiful dignity my hey everybody so
dandy the way everything because well if
netiquette cured Nick nothing ray
mutated and you're in babe I missed a
meeting early sweet
bacon baby face Naomi sour sale rate
stands triumphantly Monica stands behind
her hit wilderness expression what did I
just say I'll make some tea
you're really rush this up that's a
guess it's down with a blank expression
on her face staying at nothing so this
is why I say your is vice president I
whispered to Monica she nuts in return
to be honest I might come off as a good
leader and I can organize things but I'm
not very good with people I couldn't
even bring myself to interject as
president that's kind of embarrassing to
me huh nah it's like I can't blame you I
wasn't able to say anything either
well I guess I mean Sarah is amazing in
her own ways isn't she you could say
that she might be an airhead but
sometimes it's weirdly suspicious that
she knows exactly what she's doing
I see take good care of her okay I would
hate to see her again herself hurt that
makes the two of us you can count on me
Monica smiles sweetly at me causing my
stomach's to not she's such a gent such
a genuine person really does make a good
president regardless of what she says if
only I could get a chance to talk to her
a little bit more okay everyone it's
just about time for us to leave how did
you feel about sharing phones even black
poppy well I
I'd say it was worth it he was all right
but we'll mostly pizza pie how about you
yeah I'd say the same it was neat thing
to talk about with everyone awesome in
that case we'll do the same thing
tomorrow and maybe you learned something
from your friends team so your bunks
will turn out even better I think to
myself I did learn a little bit more
about the kind of poems everyone likes
with any luck that means I can at least
do a better job impressing those I want
to
I'm out to myself with new found
determination baby wiki sure let's go
say your e-beam send me it truly has
been a wireless and say alright now
spent this much time together I can't
really say I'm not enjoying it either
[Music]
sorry about what happened earlier what
do you mean you know between uranus aki
does that thing happen often
it's really the first time it's it
really key
they primitive when you could be you
don't you don't hate no I don't hate
them I just wanted your opinion that's
all I can see why they make good friends
with you you need to be it's nice that I
got to spend time with you in the claim
but I think so you don't meet everyone
it's make me the happy and I think
everyone likes you to you
that's hey every dude going to be famous
V sign it looked like Sarah still hasn't
caught on to the counter situation I
made sure being friends with Evernote is
nice but does it really need to stop
here we'll just have to see what the
future holds saiary iPad so Yuri on the
shoulder I said that more to myself than
to her but it's easy to use Saori as an
internal monologue sometime okay yeah
let's do this
I have to write another poem let's do
that in the next episode really enjoying
this game it's really well done I'm
really kidding me you know what plot
twist is coming and but I'm just
enjoying it for what it is right now
surprisingly I hope you enjoy it as well
if you did I really appreciate leaving
it like sharing this watching this and
then seeing you tomorrow in another
episode squad fam